Hello!
It's blooms in time!
Howdy, dody!
Howdy.
Why are we saying howdy?
Um...
Blooms?
Anybody?
Anybody up for a round of...
Blooms?
Yes.
Ice Monkey.
That guy has to be 0, 0, 0.
So, today I kind of want to do a challenge where I went
to...
I think last time I played, I just got recently kind of over
100?
Maybe?
Today, today we will do 200, I think.
As you can see, my highest round of all time is 183.
So I'm kind of close.
If anything, I'm kind of a genius.
A veritable cornucopia of games and streamers to watch.
And I'm watching this girl play a flash game.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Is it really from E-Bomb's world?
Blueberry.
Seeing as mint is a wall.
Level 200, here we come.
What do you mean by that?
Why am I a wall?
Where is the ice monkey?
He's coming!
Aren't you here for me too?
Are you only here for ice monkey?
Come on.
Ice Monkey when we see Ice Monkey.
Chibi Minto.
I thought it kind of matched the vibes with this game.
Because I feel like a baby.
Actually, no.
There's a lot of strategy in this game.
Sniper Monkey is my top monkey.
I didn't know Sada was my top hero, though.
Oh, wait.
No, that makes sense.
I use her the most.
I forgot that I...
I got her the skin.
I bought the skin, you guys.
Except I didn't spend real money.
You don't have to worry about that.
Jihiru Magic Knights Ray-Earth is getting into anime.
I did!
There's like so many.
Also, not only just Magic Knights Ray-Earth, but also Rosa
Versailles is getting a new movie that's animated by Mappa.
I'm shocked.
And Ranma, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And Ranma, it's so crazy.
Oh.
Um, let me know.
Is the music too loud?
To me, it feels loud.
Maybe because the song just drives me crazy.
Which one should we do, guys?
Let's do a warm-up or something.
Uh, I was playing balloons earlier.
bonus rewards what kind of bonus it's loud okay so it's not
just me
is that better the soup eyes for ice monkey I'll pass it
along this will cover the entire cost for you to buy killer
is dead on sale in the I'm bribing you to play a terrible
game I love.
What is it?
I'll look it up right now.
Killer is dead.
I'm looking it up.
I'm looking it up right now.
I just watched the podcast.
Is TradeWins 2 the old pirate game you were talking about?
Let me see.
Yo, this game has mixed reviews.
What are you trying to get me to play?
Oh, it's Grasshopper, though.
Maddie.
Um, um, what was I looking up?
Oh, yeah, Trade Wins, hold on.
Trade Wins, too.
It doesn't sound like it, but it might be.
I don't think so.
I remember more of the ships being, like, a top-down 2D when
they're going around.
But it looks kind of similar, I think.
I think you're on the right path there, David.
Hmm.
Hmm, hmm, hmm.
Maybe that means someone randomized the order of the
reviews.
All Suda51 games have mixed reviews.
You're a suit.
Playing balloons, too, and the overlapping BGMs is a trip.
Don't worry, we'll start right now.
Where are we dropping, boys?
Is this Mr. Beast Monkey?
Mondo Zappa, my beloved.
My beloved.
Kill the past, play the meager yoker.
Yes?
Oh my gosh.
You can tell that I'd never have been to this page because I
didn't even know that it's what's called a Mr. Beast
awesomer pack.
It's ten dollars.
Buy it.
What does it come with?
Exclusive avatar!
And banner for your profile.
10,000 monkey bucks.
Powerful tier 5 insta dart monkey.
Tier 5 insta bomb shooter.
Tier 5.
I never use any of those anyways.
So I don't need them.
I never use them anyway.
Let's go!
I've been trying to...
Let's do this.
We'll do this one on hard.
Right?
Mr. Beast was...
No!
Is this clash of clans?
Clash of...
Yeah, there's one clan that's the monkey clan and one clan
that's the balloon clan.
You know?
We'll do this one on hard.
What I've been trying to do is um...
Is get my...
These guys...
Oh, wait.
Where should I stand?
Where do you guys want me?
Oh!
No no no no no!
Where do you guys want me?
Where's the best spot for me?
In the lake?
I could go right here.
No way, I'm going to be putting boats here.
At home.
I could be at the house.
I fit right in.
Oh my gosh, I look like I'm from Candyland right now.
Knock knock!
Minto's home!
Actually, I'm here to sell you something at your doorstep.
Open up!
I have real candy!
They will just buy it from you, it's real!
I'll sell you real candy!
You're taller than the house?
Wow, do you want to just not see me at all?
Here, I'll even go smaller.
I can't even...
There we go.
Now I can fit through the door perfect HOA says you can't
keep your creatures outside hey hey oh that's rude in the
loop right here but something's gonna go here me I go right
here oh my gosh me in one loop and ice monkey in the other
it's It's kind of genius.
Okay, we'll keep it like this for now.
We'll keep it like this for now.
Here, I'm going to put her right here.
I have unfinished business.
Oh, wow, it's loud.
Hold on.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's so loud.
Yes.
You know what?
I don't...
She's not as fun as Quincy.
Yes.
yes I'm doing my part over here
yes yes yes would you condemn ice monkeys oh you're right if
I put ice monkey here he'll have to work oh did you guys
hear that?
hi Paz hi little baby girl what are you doing in here You
want in my chair?
You want in my chair?
No, don't plop.
No!
That's my cat.
Let's see.
Who should we...
60 days!
Let's hear it for 60 days!
Woohoo!
60 days!
That was a long time.
Thank you!
Let's see.
I'm going to put in a...
boat monkey right here right here okay we'll alternate this
will be the boat this will be the sub this will be the sub
this will be the boat ah there's a man in my house
i think we go zero two two made monkey
Rubbery.
Don't look at me like that.
Why are you looking at me like that?
What do you want?
What do you want little girl?
You're so crazy.
You're just a crazy little girl.
It's my cat.
She's so crazy.
I love her though.
She's so funny.
There's a house around your man.
Oh my god, he's so fast!
Wait, where's the other one?
He's like here?
Ah!
Sorry.
Level up.
How many have you killed?
Oh.
I want to see Ice Monkey Juggle.
Where should we put Ice Monkey?
I think we could place Ice Monkey in a good spot that, um...
That allows for optimal entertainment for everybody.
Oh my gosh, look!
his range is really bad if he just stands right here
everyone will be oh my gosh he can put him right on top what
if i put ice monkey right underneath me wait will it look
like i'm juggling if ice monkey is underneath me if i'm on
top of ice monkey but then he'll work i'll just sell him
before any bloop any balloons get okay hold on i'm gonna
juggle watch me juggle isn't
that crazy can do nowadays.
Just like the thumbnail.
It's true.
I need a monkey asset to put on top.
Okay, ice monkey.
I don't want...
Ah, I'm juggling!
Drop your head.
Wait, hold on.
You're kind of a genius?
Oh!
I'm the monkey now.
Wait, hold on.
Let me also get rid of the shadow.
For immersion's sake.
Oh my gosh, I look just like this monkey.
Oh, I'm scratching myself!
Ew!
Wait, hold on.
I think I need to move.
Anybody coming in is going to be like, where's the streamer
at?
So talented.
Watch me do it fast.
Watch.
Are you watching?
Oh!
I can do it fast.
I can do it slow.
I'm a multi-talented monkey.
I'm not even playing attention.
Don't.
Ice monkey!
No!
That wasn't supposed to happen.
Ice monkey was supposed to remain pure.
He's not a killer.
Ice monkey was never supposed to...
Oh, I'm kind of cut off.
Ice monkey was never supposed to be a killer.
What have you done?
You've tainted Ice Monkey!
Anyway.
I'll stand right here.
You kind of can't see what I'm choosing, but that's okay
too.
I'll just explain it with my words.
You enjoy all the monkeying around, don't you?
Let's make a sub.
What are you doing?
Okay.
Whoa!
You have permanently unlocked monkey upgrades.
No!
Wait, what are they talking about?
What are they talking about?
Huh?
I'm confused.
tutorial jump scare why did that happen
I should probably like start buying things
stand on the boat when it gets bigger yeah good idea
I never even used a single knowledge point before
andrega Thank you.
Thank you for not holding your phone.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Also, I've been leveling up my...
My...
My plane monkey.
In fact, we'll put him...
We'll throw him in, too.
Put him in, coach.
I'm going to put him down here.
But then I'm going to buy...
Nice.
More money, please!
I should start...
I should start doing farms too when I can.
Seepimiento is just the cutest...
Oh, since it's...
I put the shadow because it's kind of hard to see me, I
feel.
Since I feel like my colors kind of blend in.
My feet are kind of cut off too.
There we go.
So, hopefully it's not too weird though.
It being there.
There we go.
It works well?
That's good.
Now she poops.
Proper ghostly aura.
Hoki-doki.
Is that the Minto from Minto Gaming?
Freeze those blues!
No freeze!
He's not allowed to kill.
He's not a killer.
Ice Monkey has to stand all the way back here.
And juggle.
He's actually...
He's actually a homeowner.
He owns this home.
Or... He's the one manning...
No, no.
I like him better here.
He's the homeowner.
Good job, Ice Monkey.
Keep doing your work.
Keep doing the good work that you do.
I'm gonna do double shot
he's just chilling yeah let him stay let him stay let him
juggle and then I'm gonna do the wrap of fire as you see as
you can see I have not touched this I have not touched
middle plane at all but I'm oh oh I can't unlock this one oh
my gosh I'm so silly I didn't realize nice and I can do
these if I wanted to very large bomb I made a ghost oh she
possessed innocent ice monkey and turn her him into a killer
B B TD 6 light novel planes bottom path is the goal oh yeah
I've been doing this one like basically it's like
exclusively that's why I have it unlocked first cuz it's so
good but I've never I haven't I only did it recently so I
haven't had a chance to try out the most with this today we
will see what the big plan is I'm excited I'm excited I'm so
excited and then at the honing one oh it's just so powerful
it's such a good it's a good monkey look at her though she's
crap I wish there was a good place to put laser monkey here.
Gunner monkey?
Gunner monkey, my beloved.
This guy owns.
Maybe if I, like, stick him and have him go, like, up like
that.
You think that will work?
I put him, like, here and go like...
Like that?
Projectile spam makes it look like a Danmaku game.
From one corner to the other, diagonal?
Wait, what?
We could honestly have a gunner monkey on every...
We'll put him here, we'll put him there, everywhere,
anywhere that there's a bit of a straight line.
I think this one's the longest, though.
And it also reaches the most...
Okay, I think, like, here.
And then, just like...
Yeah!
Right?
That should work!
I just got home to watch the stream.
And at the best part, you place the ice monkey.
Oh.
Ice monkey is gone!
Rip ice monkey.
Oh no, he's up here.
I forgot that I put him up there.
How are you doing up there, ice monkey?
He's like, zero, zero, zero, just as you want it.
He's so right.
I hate this.
Yes.
After I can afford a farm.
Stop bad-mouthing an ice monkey.
My bad.
Maybe I put him over here.
So typically I like to put two and two next to each other
and then this guy in the middle so that he can generate more
bananas.
I do sometimes try to do three like I'll do this one and
then this one in the middle because it'll collect the income
radius and then this one on one's whatever side but I don't
think we have room for three and also him okay wait we can
do one here one here then maybe him here maybe hmm balloons
tensai
I prefer banks when there's low space.
Are they smaller?
Is that why it's better?
What type of monkey is the box of bananas?
This one?
But I feel like this one...
Okay, correct me if I'm wrong.
I feel like the top route is kind of inconvenient.
Well, until you get Monkey Wall Street.
But also, I feel like...
I feel like it just doesn't generate as much value.
bananas as it costs.
Am I wrong?
I feel like there's...
Where is the goat?
Pat?
Fusty.
Top path is best income, but you have to collect it.
Oh, really?
So it is actually...
See, but if you have this one and then this one, this will
just collect it, everything in the radius.
So it's really awesome.
That's why you put it in the middle.
But...
But it's so inconvenient having this one.
They cost so much.
Both of them cost so much.
I mean, all three of them cost so much.
Hmm...
But...
Do Banks then?
I like this one too though.
But I guess we don't need I like how it generates lives each
round too.
I like these two the most.
I'm gonna go with those two.
You guys, I'm a level 180 player.
Please understand.
I have experience.
Let's get this one too.
We'll do the...
We'll do...
Do I want...
We'll do the bottom path first.
Because we're gonna have some merchantmen.
I love how well your TV model fits into the game.
It's too cute.
Don't miss any balloons now.
What if I...
What if I stand and guard the exit instead?
Actually, I'm standing to the side because I'm like, Sensei
in Blue Archive.
I'm the Sensei to these monkeys.
I tell them how to...
do.
I tell them what to do.
The last line of the fence is Minto.
That's cheating.
How so?
Oh!
Moab!
How do you live?
How did I live?
Guys, I don't know if we're gonna make it to 200 today.
Or, I mean, in this round.
That's okay, though.
Oh, another thing I've been trying to upgrade are my...
Are these guys, too.
Grand Sabatura.
They did not handle it.
Not at all.
Um...
I'll hold off on that.
Until we upgrade, um...
These ones.
I'll just...
just hover for now.
Ice monkey made you live.
You're so right.
Oh, and I gotta get this one too.
It's so good.
Almost.
Yippee!
Okay, now we should be good for a while.
Now we should actually be good for a while.
Oh my god.
They're flying everywhere.
There's just stuff all over this Korean.
It's just a warm-up round.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
all right i'm gonna change it to the marketplace clear up
any monkey i mean bananas all right let's see who do i want
to throw into the ring next i'm gonna i'm i might actually
just add druid monkey i'm gonna put him up there you're
probably like why that's such a weird place first of all the
guy is gonna have range because he's gonna have the druid of
the jungle but also i need him to the banks.
I need him next to the banks.
I mean to the... Here we go.
Okay, now he's got that good old reach.
Why?
That's such a weird place.
I'm so glad you asked that sage!
Me!
New Bloom's DLC with Chibi Minto as new character?
Kawaii!
I feel like, though, also, I feel like I would fit into
Cookie Run Kingdom even more so.
What do you guys think?
I feel like I'd fit in cookie run even more.
Mint cookie.
Mint chocolate cookie.
Oh my gosh.
Girl Scouts should collab with me.
I basically am the thin mint.
Or maybe not the thin part.
I'm gonna save up for the laser cannons.
Thick mint!
Nice.
Good job, everybody.
Good job, team.
I'm gonna add in another sub.
And another ship.
This ship, this one will be middle.
Monkey pirate.
This one will be top.
He'll be the flagship, the carrier.
CB Mint fits in the Annie Kutsi game.
Oh my gosh.
We won't die this time.
See?
We're all good.
This guy will be the sub-commander.
What's this one?
Oh, which one should I do?
Allows long-range targeting of balloons and radius of your
other tower.
intel is so good, right?
024 glue gunner destroys with Sada.
Trust.
024 glue gunner.
Okay, IDK.
Are you sure because your name is IDK?
Do you really trust...
Should I trust someone who doesn't know?
Top path is stronger.
What, for the sub?
I already have this... Oh, wait, this one?
The energizer?
I mean, well... There you go.
Don't worry, guys.
We'll get to it.
a little size.
I'm going to put him right here.
Next to her.
What was it?
024?
I actually usually do that one.
Actually, that's usually the one that I go with.
Hey, why aren't you doing your job, idiot?
Oh, there...
My bad.
You were trying to do your job.
There were camos.
I knew that.
Nice-oo!
What are we doing?
Oh, this one.
Read Sada level 7 and 11 ability.
I don't read.
This cute TV model makes me want to grab it like that
hand-grabbing the gerbil rat meme.
Don't grab me, please.
Maybe avoid grabbing the minto with that.
excessive force, okay?
Just saying.
I think you have a problem if you're, like...
Like, I know cuteness aggression is a thing, but, like...
I'm just saying.
I get so loud!
Oh!
I'm gonna turn it down just a little bit more.
Okay.
New Minto cookie is extra small, but with lots of pop.
I don't know.
I've thought about, like, merch like that.
That would be kind of fun.
But I think, I don't know.
I feel like cookies are pretty easy to ship, right?
Because they're like...
Because they don't really expire so quickly, so...
Get it!
Blune.
That's right.
They got a good shelf life.
They might crumble during shipping.
That's true.
But like, if I ship them right, it should be fine.
Actually, I should have put this guy over here.
I should have put this guy up here.
Because then he'll reach even further.
I'm going to sell him.
Nice.
Good job, everybody.
I'm going to also do our next farm.
Oh, my gosh.
Will it fit?
How?
Why?
Oh, oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
It's still in his range, right?
It's still in his range.
and this one will be a bank
did they still have the helicopter monkey or upgrade that
lets you move monkeys or was that only in four oh I don't
think so is that a helicopter up that's so nice what the
heck
middle path oh it's still a thing oh I don't think I have
that I want to unlock, that's probably why.
I don't have it unlocked.
Maybe car, thanks for the gift.
Okay, now I don't have to worry about it.
Let's see.
Where is my helicopter?
Oh, here.
Oh, wrong one.
Oh, wait.
See, I'm waiting to do this one.
I'm waiting to unlock this one, but I'm quite far away.
There's a way to go.
Batman can move things too.
Oh.
The Chinook flows back more boons and gains abilities, drops
lives and cash crates and can pick up and redeploy most
monkey types.
What?
Maybe I should unlock it then.
Monkey Marine!
Is worth?
I always, I've been wanting to, I haven't been able to get
this one either.
I just recently unlocked it.
Well maybe I'll go with this one then instead.
Okay, let's, let's, um, let's save up for, uh, let's save up
for a, what's the word?
Helicopter monkey.
I need this guy all the way up too, though.
Let's see, I'm gonna put it right, hmm, hmm, right next to,
right next to plane monkey.
This is the airport, everybody.
Forgot to use this almost at three months.
Thank you, Elios!
Thank you!
Wait.
Welcome to Membuship, but it was retracted.
Who was that?
Um, wait.
Uh, this one.
Uh, okay.
Middle path.
But I like the pursuit, so I don't have to do anything.
I feel like every path for the helicopter is pretty good.
They each have, like, really good strengths.
If you don't have one M on round 100-ish, I'm leaving, but
seriously, I hope you have a Oh.
One M.
I am one Minto.
What are you talking about?
I literally have one M right now.
I'm one Minto.
I had one Minto.
I had one Minto from round one.
From round zero.
It said most monkey types.
What can it not do?
One order of Minto, please.
Hiya Kenny.
Hey there, Kenny.
I can't move Ice Monkey.
Oh, Temples and Air Towers.
Kuhn, what does that mean?
What does that even mean?
Who am I teasing?
What's going on?
Are you winning, Minta?
I have an extra life.
Wait, where did that... I was at, like, 48.
Where did I get the extra ones from?
Oh, it's from the bananas.
Oh, oh, oh, laser, laser, laser.
Laser, laser.
Four, five, six, seven, eight.
I love the lasers.
Can you please get the made monkey to zero?
Negative one, negative one, negative one.
Like intelligence or...
Oh, I forgot to...
Even more.
Stop appearing!
You little freak down there!
Kumu-sama!
Thanks for the gift, thank you!
Hi, Mint, hello, Jabob.
Alright, let's get an aircraft carrier up in here.
We got little planes, we got big planes, we got helicopters,
we got planes everywhere, we got planes in your brains.
Rutan won!
Thanks for the time.
You have to know who she caught me.
I sniped you.
Don't you know?
I have good vision.
I ice monkey.
No, hello there.
That's probably what Ice Monkey sounds like.
Kind of like a nerd.
Eighty-six thousand, it's craziness.
Let's go for the first strike capability next.
So far so good though.
I say, until not.
Please upgrade Ice Monkey.
Whoa.
Must be your first time here.
What am I looking for?
Oh, this one.
2000.
I'll take it.
We're close.
Yes.
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
Oh, come on.
I'm so close to him.
Look, we're almost around 80.
I really need to get this.
guy up too though i do i do so he can start giving me more
money and more lives pizza welcome to membership thank you
but the game your dad played the admiral sea battles it's
not up oh oh oh oh that was so close it's not on seam and it
is obscure i don't think the game my dad is obscure, but let
me see.
Admiral Sea Battles.
Oh!
I think so!
Wait a second.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Maybe not, maybe not.
But it looks very similar.
It looks really, really similar.
There was one thing about the game.
You could go to the towns and stuff.
You could, like, dock on the ports and, like, go into town.
So it wasn't always on the sea.
But, like, the picture frames look so familiar.
Oh, my God.
I don't think it is, though.
Ah!
It looks so familiar at first.
Oh, my gosh.
It looks so similar.
Almost found it.
Almost.
I almost nailed it.
You really did.
Thank you, though, Kevi.
Thank you.
So close.
Sheesh.
I like how we'd be beaming up the I wonder if it's like Why
can't he be here?
Is this so messed up?
Like not even here I wonder if he's If the farm was here
though If this would still gobble it up Like I'm gonna Also
get maybe some wizard monkeys I feel like we need something
in here Right Hmm Hmm you know magic monkeys yeah i'm trying
to also get them up so i can unlock this thing something to
remove camo this one removes it right well it's only
periodic wait periodically reveals oh but permanently but
it's only periodically
what do i want to add but also ninja Monkeys will strip it,
right?
Oh, it can strip the camel.
It doesn't mean it will entirely.
Strop.
We'll do first for that one.
First.
Sticky bomb?
You're a buccaneer for DDTs.
Like, uh...
This is the buccaneer, right?
What?
Nope.
This one, the sticky bomb.
Probably good to have, though, right?
Good, because they can also attack the, what's it called?
Um, the camel boons.
It's good.
There we go.
Yeah, throw your little bombs.
Throw your little bombs.
But, uh...
Hmm.
And then I do...
I'll do this one.
There we go.
That should be good.
Oh my god, 0-25.
That's what I did.
Maybe I'm getting better at this game.
Oh, we did it!
Yumi!
Alright, free play time.
Let's keep going.
You guys, we're almost to 100.
Which means we're almost halfway to 200.
I really want to get this...
Oh.
really want to get this guy up i like him being up so much
hmm 43.
we have quite a few though that we just gotta keep saving
money chopper upgrade oh yeah thank you it's so hefty wait
what does the ability do uh oh wait blow the back many more
balloons and gains abilities drops lives and cash crates i
don't want to like does it will it always pick them up
though it drops money and lives oh oh oh
here's the cash one oh okay i see it i missed it before this
here it comes oh here it comes oh we got it
We're slowly but surely getting back to 100.
With sound on, the umpalupa monkeys play music.
What sound?
Oh, this?
Yes?
Wait, why is it?
Yeah?
Yes?
Why isn't he speaking anymore?
Quincy!
Where are you?
It's because I silenced him for too long.
It means no.
No!
I won't take no as an answer!
Quincy, Quincy, are you here?
Oh boy!
Thanks for the gift.
Quincy, Quincy, speak to me!
Quincy!
Oh!
I heard it.
I heard him in the...
Yes?
Quincy!
Yay!
Speak to me!
Hold on, you guys.
I'm going to get the Ouija board.
Quincy.
Are you here?
Quincy, if you're here, give us a sign.
Quincy!
Give us a sign!
Bunny, welcome to membership, thank you.
Sorry, it's a really tumultuous time right now.
I don't think Quincy's here.
Quincy!
Quincy, are you here?
Quincy, are you alive?
Yes?
Cool!
Oh my
gosh, the Luigi board always works.
Have you guys ever tried calling me on the Luigi board
before?
Rico Mortis has sent in.
No, no, no.
I'm a ghost of...
Return to your ancestors.
I don't want to hear you anyway.
It's because not yet.
Every day.
You don't know my number.
You don't know my number, silly.
You're not going to know how to contact me.
You're going to get some random ghosts.
That's bad.
Don't just call people.
Don't just call random people.
Oh my gosh, we're so close.
I just realized how much money we are.
We're doing all right.
When do the DDTs start coming in?
I'm scared.
When do we get the DDTs?
So close.
Around 90.
Okay, okay.
Soon then, soon.
Is your number 44444444444?
A really dumb number to have if you're a ghost.
Because, like, it's so obvious.
If it's...
I mean...
What?
Well, I was.
Or actually, I don't know.
What is a ghost anyway?
Oh!
Here he comes.
Oh my gosh, he looks just like the guys from Outer Wilds.
2 2 Murphy, thank you for the 4-4.
4-4.
Appreciate it.
I think because I'm a ghost, whatever the gen is, I am that,
I think.
Be right back.
Gonna call this ghost number I saw.
No real, no real reason.
So wait, what is it now?
Gen...
Gen
Alpha?
Gen Alpha, yeah.
Join us zoomers.
You guys are old now.
Zoomers are old now.
It's all about the Alpha, baby.
Oh no, I forgot that I don't have this unlocked.
Oh gosh.
That's okay though.
Which one?
Should- Oh!
Wow!
Oh my gosh, that was so close.
Ah, that was close.
Let's see.
What should I save up for?
Is this Mint I'll have two number nines, number nine, large.
I don't have my piece of paper today.
Also, you have the wrong number.
Mint was here when the Declaration of Independence was news.
I stole the Declaration of Independence.
in that movie i'm nicholas cage i'm a millennial i prefer
phone calls text can be ignored but the ringing ringing
ringing will never stop today i went to go pick up some food
i didn't realize they were calling me but i was driving i
was pulling into the parking lot and they were calling me
and i was like i was like i know number calling me i'm not
gonna answer i i I always googled the numbers, you know,
before I pick up.
And I googled it and it was the restaurant.
I was like, but I was like, I had already parked.
So I was like, I'll just, if they need me for something,
I'll just go inside and I'll see, I'll see why they're
calling me.
And when I went inside, oh my gosh, it was like a bunch of
teenage girls and they were just like, why didn't she pick
up?
Oh my God, I kept calling and calling.
They called me twice, first of all, but I was driving.
this is so awkward I could never go there again you guys I
could never go there
again they were like who are you or what do you want like or
rather they were like what do you want to order and I was
like I'm I'm picking up and they were like what's the name
and I was like and they were like and they like looked at
each other and they started giggling and they were like We
tried calling you.
I was like, I was, I was driving!
I can't go there anymore.
I can't go, I can't, I can't.
I can't go there anymore, you guys.
Holy cow, it gives you a lot of lives.
Nice.
Sopping wet cat energy, meito.
Please help the ants are descending on my apartment.
What?
Call an exterminator!
Ants.
I once had a sugar ant problem.
Well, I was a kid.
I caused it.
We, we, my, I was, I was gifted some, like, some sugar
candies.
Well, I guess candy.
It was, I don't remember.
It was like some kind of, like some kind of rice candy.
and I really liked it and but I couldn't get it often
because um it was from someone that would like travel and um
so I courted them and and then and then we got sugar ants it
was my fault my parents were really mad they were like why
don't you eat the candies I was like guys I'll never
be able to have them and they're like you can't have them
anymore now because they're covered in sugar ants i really
messed up that one you guys i really i really messed that up
i missed that one oh the ddt we made it we lived we lived i
feel like okay i need to start getting some other stuff for
the ddt's right
You missed that one up, Chief.
I know, I know, I know.
Oh, this one we can upgrade, though.
And how much money do we...
Oh, I'll take that.
Nice.
Love how she even bounces just by speaking.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah.
Monkey town?
Oh.
on what though hmm on everybody everybody gets you get
monkey town you'll get monkey town you'll get monkey town
gotta make a move to a town that's right for me
Simba thank you for the thank you for the 15 gift thank you
thank you so much
Thank you so much.
Appreciate it.
Peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep,
peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep.
Let's see.
Maybe Monkey Town here.
If I expand the radius, how far will it go?
Oh.
Oh!
I could have used your ability.
No!
Okay.
Hold on.
Ben!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you!
Big plan.
We're so close!
We're so close to... Well, I mean...
Yes, but also so far.
I think... I don't know.
I think I might upgrade laser before I upgrade big plan.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Maybe I should just go for the big plan.
Apache Dart ship.
I like that one a lot.
I did go for this one.
But maybe I will also do the Apache Dart ship.
Because that's the one that I have completely upgraded.
So...
There's someone asking about what ice monkey's doing up
there.
Yeah, he's providing entertainment.
Iceman!
Thank you for the message.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much.
What's going on?
Why?
What's happening?
Why are there so many negatives?
Why?
Go on the helipad.
He's gonna land on top of me.
I'm going to get crushed.
I'm going to literally die again.
You know what?
Let's just try it.
Even though I'm scared.
Actually, hold on.
If I put it here...
See, why can't...
Oh my gosh.
Wait!
I haven't set it down yet!
Guys, this is not good.
This is not good.
Whoa!
I don't even know if this works.
Oh!
This is good.
Oof.
I know what I should add.
I should add in some...
Sniper monkeys.
I'm gonna put them here, because what I'm gonna do is do
this.
There we go.
And also, I would like...
Hmm, I'm trying to decide.
Because I feel like I can put another monkey by the village,
it'll be more worth it.
Because this guy can be... do this.
Jajun, jajun, jajun, jang, like that.
Make him super duper fast.
I wanted to play monkeys along with you, but I'm still going
to work for the next 24 hours?
Hour?
Are you okay?
Do you believe that love can balloon on the battlefield?
I'm gonna move myself.
I don't like being over here.
I feel lonely.
I'm gonna stay right here.
Not so much.
We can keep you company.
Okay.
You better.
I'm holding you to that.
I don't know which one I want to upgrade first.
Actually, there is the sub too.
I said I was going to add that sub guy and I completely
forgot.
That one.
There we go.
This one, like...
Oh my god.
I didn't see...
I didn't expect...
to see so many DDTs.
Upgrade the bank.
But it's like, it's the loan.
I guess I'll take it.
Oh!
It's this guy.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this one.
Oh, God.
I forgot about this guy.
There we go.
We're good.
Yippee!
Round 100.
Easy, mostly.
easy mostly baby
gotta upgrade this guy what does this one do again yeah i'm
gonna upgrade upgrade this one upgrade oh that was it oh
my gosh oh my gosh but it's such a crazy amount of ddts it's
really scary oh my god oh wait there we go maybe that'll
help a little Maybe that'll help a little bit.
Yeah!
Oh, you know what, also?
Hold on.
I know what one is really, really, really good to have.
And that is...
Hold on.
Let me see.
This guy.
No, no, no.
Just kidding.
I'm a liar.
This guy.
He pushes all of them back.
Today's my birthday.
Could I get a minty, fresh, happy birthday song?
Of course!
birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear
Nathaniel happy birthday to you so let's get in uh this guy
in fact he should be good here because he'll just he'll i
think he reaches across like the whole map he's crazy
And if he's within range of the of the town, maybe he'll...
Maybe he'll be able to also do DDTs.
I don't know.
It might be a stretch, but...
Okay.
Now we save up.
Whoa!
My debt is gone!
Yippee!
I forgot about this guy, too.
Use IMF loan for more loans.
Alright.
I need more money, you guys.
I need more money.
Oh, wait.
I don't want to do the Monkey City.
Wait, which one is this again?
Increases influence.
No, I'm not yet.
No, no.
I think we're okay for now.
Rob your own bank.
Boats are great for money.
You're right.
You are right.
Let's get ourselves a merchant, man.
I'm gonna keep him out of the range.
Well, he doesn't need to be...
Like, this is taking up a spot, right?
Because he...
He can do guys.
Let's do that.
Whoa!
He looks so cool.
I don't think I've ever seen this one, but what?
More money!
Yeah!
Whoa, nice.
Oh my gosh, that strike worked so well.
It worked so well.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Do I hate these ones?
Oh my gosh, I hate them so much.
Woof!
Woof, woof, woof.
Woof, woof, woof, woof.
108.
It is chaotic.
It's absolutely chaotic.
It's chaos everywhere.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, jam, thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Oh, nice.
I'm going to upgrade.
Wait, uh, you.
Wow, he's huge.
This poor sub.
Okay.
easy I gotta upgrade this guy too but I think maybe super
storm is our priority or like you know this guy too I don't
know there's so many there's so many so many upgrades so
little time and money so little money mostly silver empress
thanks for the vibe good dude attack shooters see the thing
about my Attack shooters is...
This is one, right?
I haven't upgraded them very much.
So it's kind of like not great to have them.
But...
Can I fit more than what?
It won't be like a circle of them, but...
Ooh!
Only one.
No!
So sad.
Have you played around with the Beast Handler?
Just a tiny, tiny...
but not a super lot but I love that there's dinosaurs my
favorite part can drag down ZOMGs geez are they super good
the beast handler what update did I miss welcome to bloons
2024 do i want to keep this guy
yeah i'll keep them
i'll keep them i'll
keep them ice monkey monkey is carrying hard uh absolute oh
absolutely he is of course he is it's ice monkey Look how
cool she looks!
I don't know if you guys noticed, but I got the skin.
She looks so awesome!
Max level!
Look at her!
She's got, like, an extra hand coming out.
And she and I have the same sleeves.
Yeah, she looks so cool.
Look how many things are flying around, too.
Maybe I should...
Can it fit here?
All I think about it.
Nope.
I was just going to put them there, but...
I don't think it'll fit.
Zhang Shi Sata is the goat.
I know.
It's so cool.
Looks like that dark stalker's character.
I know who you're talking about.
I think that's just the aesthetic of, like, Zhang Shi,
though, right?
Sorry, hold on.
No, I'm going to say...
I think I'm going to keep saving up a little bit.
Because this is really good.
the super storm i'm telling you it's whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa okay oh we made it through i didn't know
oh that one was tough i feel like i should also upgrade this
though but no no no no it's okay oh but i also want to no no
it's fine it's fine but this also boosts the damage of the
113 that's right you can put the monkeys on the helipad i
completely forgot thank you for telling this these ones yes
i completely forgot about that who should we put we could
put sniper monkeys how are you doing down here ninja monkey
are you okay i could put another ninja monkey maybe like a
grandmaster ninja monkey an ice monkey
alchemist oh so he can start like throwing things to people.
Might be good, actually, because, like, he throws right, the
Berserker Brew, giving extra damage, range, and attack
speed.
I think that'd be good.
Throw the Ice Monkey.
We have Ice Monkey!
You have Ice Monkey!
Oh, wait.
I don't want to use all my money.
Okay.
You know what?
I can just go in there.
I can go into that!
Hey, are you not throwing anything or what are you doing?
What are you doing, guy?
You're not throwing anything.
Yeah, they're not affected.
He buffs the other towers.
Yeah, but don't they have- doesn't it show- like see?
It only- he has a buff.
But this guy doesn't have a buff.
Even though he's in his range.
This one doesn't have a buff.
Do the planes get buffs?
The buffs are not permanent.
Let's see if it shows up.
I guess he had the buff.
And then he lost the buff.
Throw faster!
Throw faster, potion man!
What are you doing?
Oh, it only shows during the round?
No, that's not true at all!
Because what does this mean then?
Anyway, you know what?
I don't know anything.
I don't know anything about this game.
I don't know why I act like a genius.
Burn noises.
I'm just gonna go into more debt.
I'm gonna go into more debt.
Everybody, we're so close.
I'll feel more safe when we have the super storm.
I know I should upgrade pirate lord.
But...
it's fine oh my god oh my god they're so crazy calm down
chill out chill out I'm gonna give this guy him that
uh oh uh oh yeah yeah kiwawa
Oh, I didn't even use that.
Wow.
Oh, a storm is brewing.
Flying Fortress is a good one.
What's that one?
What's Flying Fortress?
Oh, also we have this one I want to save up for too.
I'm telling you, once we get the ray of doom, it's crazy.
All right.
I'm just going to go for it.
I'm just going to...
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no.
Oh, no, no, there's two of them!
Oh, there's three of them!
That was a bad surprise.
Oh, my God.
I'm kind of going to debt.
Here we go.
See, it pushes them back.
It's so awesome.
See?
Oh, it feels so good.
Yeah, get back to the...
beginning you dummies
nice nice what am i looking at monkey
yeah it's so it's so it's so strong i'm telling you now oh
collect my money i'm in debt okay now we can start upgrading
some of these other guys that probably have needed it for a
while while but he's just blowing him back he's like he's
like get to the get to the front of the line get to the
front of the line
i was also thinking maybe um i haven't put in a bomb yet
like at a bomb blitz or a moab eliminator might be good or
something You crazy.
What's a barricade?
Oh, yeah, the big plane.
It's a lot of money, though.
I feel like, yes, I will invest.
But...
Or rather, I'll save up, but I should get some of these guys
higher so we feel a little more comfortable.
Oh, wait, it's a 5-5-5 tower.
5 5 5 wait you can do that wait is it like is it like wait
no not you no wait just kidding is it like is it like this
guy is this the paragon this thing i
mean look how much guys i can barely get to 100 000 how the
hell would i even afford this how would i even afford this
my monkey economy is not really thriving, okay?
We're in struggling times right now.
Let's go into debt!
Yeah!
There's been times, though, that I've had a lot of monkey
money.
I think it was the one game that I got to 183 at.
Half the screen is farms.
Farms do all the damage.
As the balloons go by, it takes their money, and it makes
them sad, and then they pop.
It's really tragic.
Don't think there's much I can do anyway.
Oh!
Hi, I'm so sorry!
Let me let her out.
Let me let my cat out real quick.
I thought she was part of the music.
Let me let you out, baby girl.
Okay.
Alrighty.
I might be stupid to do this, but...
See, he's blowing him away.
It's so good.
Yeah.
Just keep on blowing.
Buy a couple more pirate trade ships maybe.
You're probably right.
And this one, it'll also increase the...
You know what?
This will be a row of pirate ships.
Or merchant men.
This is our money row right here.
Money row.
Oh, I'm out of money.
There we go.
Go!
Oh, nice.
Oh, they got lots of money.
Hey, man.
Hello.
How much do we have in the bank?
Not so much.
It's kind of OP, isn't it?
It's kind of OP.
This guy, I'm telling you, he's just like, nah, you will not
pass.
That's literally what he says.
Hmm.
Still haven't even upgraded this guy.
I won't lie, I've only been watching Ice Monkey juggling.
There he is.
Yeah, a little silly goofball.
Up there in the corner.
Oop.
More dead!
Nah, he's pretty cute up there.
He does a good job.
126!
One day we'll use the Ice Monkey only map, okay?
Will that make you guys feel better?
DDT incoming.
DDT taken care of.
Okay, Ice Monkey only.
How much is an Ice Monkey?
540.
Oh gosh.
I was scared for my...
I was scared for my afterlife there.
I was really...
I was really terrified, you guys.
That was dangerous.
That was really dangerous.
I want to get the bad
Mortar monkey to strip the reinforcement labs See, um,
that's another thing I haven't really used the mortar monkey
very much So, um I don't have it
Yeah, so you know, it's just kind of It's kind of tough What
you can still use them though.
Camo balloons pop there by flares lose their camouflage
permanently.
It's pretty cool.
I see, you can see I was working on it.
I was working on it.
Alright, Mortar Monkey.
You're gonna go right next to...
No, no.
You're gonna go over here.
Yeah, I... No, no.
Ice Monkey doesn't need to have hearing damage to, you know.
We could put him right here.
No, no.
We'll I'm gonna put him right here.
Set to target.
Yeah, I should be fine.
Whatever.
Thank you!
Ice, ice, ice.
Lindro Torrelli.
Thank you so much!
Signal flare!
Hey, it doesn't hurt to have him, right?
He sets off the fireworks, Guys, it's his job.
I'm in debt.
We're all good.
This is the color of Ice Monkey.
Oh, oh, oh.
Please give him a friend.
He prefers to be alone.
This is his friend.
Actually, he's scoping out this house so that he can rob it.
Ice Monkey is not a good guy.
But it's okay.
We still, we root for an anti-hero.
know um let's see oh
thank you hooray for day yippee wait no no yippee
okay there's ddt's but we're still okay kind of oh gosh kind
of reinforcement
this is not the color of ice monkey Thank
you for the aqua super Thank you Thank you, thank you, thank
you Appreciate it, thank you Thank you Um, there's also, oh
gosh, there's so many things that I want There's so many
things that I want Usually my gat, my, oh my god I always
call him the gatlin monkey My, my, my Gunner monkey has like
crazy number of kills Like this Four million- Wooah!
It's kindly Thank you for this Thank you!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Yeah, my gap, my gap monkey.
I should probably pay attention.
I should probably be paying attention.
Look at this.
Four million...
Monk...
The bloons taken out.
I wonder if I should put in Not sniper monkey If I should I
mean I I recently unlocked the sun temple But I'm too scared
to use it I'm too scared to use it But maybe like a sun
avatar
Super monkey as a treat
I get I don't think it would hurt to have it More than
anything You know what I mean But I think Maybe like here.
Because I think we need more defenses on this end.
And I'm going to epic range him.
Right?
That's what I usually do.
Yeah.
He's got the help of the...
Yeah, there we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
And we should soon be able to...
Get harnessed the powers of the...
Of the...
Of the side.
I'm never going to save up enough monkey bucks at this
point.
At this rate, I'll never have enough money to upgrade my
monkeys.
Sean.
Yeah.
I think this will help, though.
How large is this range?
This range is insane.
Maybe I should have scooted him over a little bit.
Look at the numbers fly!
Go, go!
Draw!
Kill!
Yippee!
Number go up.
Number go...
One million.
Two million.
Look.
We've had Sada the whole time and she's at two million.
Druid Monkey at five million.
This guy is so crazy.
That's why I was like, we gotta get him up there, you know.
Monkey sub isn't killed very much, but that's okay.
That's fine.
That's alright.
Three million.
Thank you!
Choo!
Guide brush, thank you!
I think this will help though.
005, Alchemist is really strong too.
Oh, I almost have it.
I think I was working on it.
I was working on it.
As you could see.
It is nice to get the stuff to, um, you know, get more
money.
He's crazy for late game?
I'll add him in then.
We'll put him in like...
Uh...
I really like this mint model.
Credit to the artist.
Thank you!
The artist is Hexo Se on Twitter, but their username is like
a lot of numbers.
I'll add it to the description.
Oh.
I meant to add it to the description of the debut stream.
Put him in the very front, Minto.
Okay.
I'm going to put him right here.
Shoo, shoo, shoo, shoo.
Let's check it out.
Let's see how it works out.
He's throwing.
We're generating cash.
We're generating oodles and doodles of cash and money.
Good job.
For super late game, he's insane.
He gets 500.
Wait, what?
Whoa!
Gosh.
Oh, I never used this enough.
The harpoon thing.
I know it's really good.
I just always forget about it.
I'll be honest.
How much is doodles?
Hmm.
A doodle is priceless.
Can you really put a price on art?
There we go, I just used it.
How much are you at?
Nice.
Um.
Gotta upgrade you too.
Gotta upgrade too many of you.
Look him!
Okay, I think we really should focus on the plane though.
And if we have to do other things in the middle, We do other
things in the middle.
Oh, give me that money.
More money.
You can use numbers or put a little drone to click for you.
A little drone.
Wait, what does that mean?
What do you mean a little drone?
Is there like a monkey that will push buttons for you?
If so, that's awesome.
140 will be the bad damage test.
I'm scared.
Oh, gosh.
Maybe we should add more monkeys.
I don't know.
Maybe we should add like another...
Maybe we should do an Apache monkey, you know?
Maybe an Apache monkey.
Hire a real monkey to present.
Oh,
the armored BA.
Oh, that's what you meant.
Oh, no.
Oh, gosh.
Wait, so that's the, it has like the little wraps around it,
right?
Why can't you be better?
Mortar monkey!
He's like, it's not my fault.
Thank you, thank you.
Clockwork, thank you.
It meant how about some gamer subs?
By using code boomer at checkout, I've had guacamole gamer
fart.
What?
Before, and it was good.
Any recommendations?
I've never had that one.
oh my gosh I think I'm gonna have gamer subs for like years
because I got an email just the other day and it was just
like your gamer subs order has been placed and I was like
who and they like gifted me all the new all the new stuff
it's like a science they just released like the scientist
and they gifted me the skateboard and the jacket and
everything it's everything
two four zero super monkeys or whatever is the robo monkey
with the village is great damage unless it has changed in
the past years oh thanks turtles i don't know if my wait
what do i have my um oh go away mortar monkey well i don't
have it up to four though for the robo monkey
are you popping me oh yeah i'm popping 140 coming up.
I'm scared.
What do you guys think I should do?
We have the master bomber.
Will that help?
Will that?
Ah!
Let's see how we do next.
Oh!
Whoa!
Gosh, it's not looking so good.
Stop it, please!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my goodness.
Middle path alchemist can remove fortifications.
This guy?
Oh, strip?
Oh, no, but it's fortified off smaller blooms.
It's not of big blooms.
We need the big, big, big, big.
We need the biggest blooms.
Hmm.
And then there's also this.
This I think actually Wizard Lord Phoenix might be really
good to have because we'll have the Phoenix out all the time
and then we can turn him into a Phoenix.
So maybe I should save up for that.
Actually.
I'm going to collect that money.
Two three is fine for RoboBunky.
I thought it was two four but the three update upgrade is
decent enough as long as you have a village.
They're cheap too.
Hmm.
But you can't remove fortified properties from BADs.
Phoenix is not good compared to Big Plain.
Yeah, but it's much cheaper.
I can't afford Big Plain by in two rounds.
That's craziness.
I'm going into debt.
Oh,
don't tell the monkeys, though.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Sell the boats.
Holy moly!
He's worth so much.
Whoa!
He's worth $28,000.
$8,000.
Monkeys and radius have increased sale value.
Well, that would be why.
Sell the boats and you get the plane?
Wait.
No?
I don't think so.
That 8,000, 8,000 is not going to equal to 9,000.
90,000.
But if I sell all three of them, maybe.
I mean, if I sell this one too, then yeah.
Okay.
Wait, so it's next round, though, right?
I have, wait.
I can do this one, and then it's the next one that I play,
right?
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, no, I was wrong!
Wait!
Sell, sell, sell!
I know.
Just cut him up a little bit.
Oh, oh.
Come on.
Come on, everybody.
Keep taking him down.
Just a little bit long.
Okay, look.
Stop juggling.
This is not a...
Ah!
There's a second one.
Please.
Um.
Uh, guys.
Guys, this isn't looking so good.
This isn't looking so good.
Oh no!
Uh.
Oh my god.
Um.
Oh.
Um, I don't even know what to put here.
Oh, goodbye, everybody.
Goodbye, round 40.
No, I just got the big plane.
What was it?
It wasn't even worth it.
No!
Ah.
I blame.
Um.
As a...
But as a Minto who has gotten to level 183 all by myself, I
blame you
guys.
No.
I blame the monkeys.
They had streaming anxiety.
They performance anxiety.
They have performance anxiety, I believe.
Ah.
I never use these.
But that's okay, I ended up, I still was able to get the
thingy, so...
I don't remember what level it was even that I got the 183
on.
Does it say?
What's that?
Oh, sharing.
Total pop count.
Look how many DDTs.
Oh, look how much cash I've generated.
Crazy.
Blame going into debt.
yeah most experienced monkey sniper monkey
insta monkey collection 33 out of 1400 holy moly golden i've
popped eight golden balloons
it says on the maps
i don't see it it's fine don't worry about it let's see
let's choose one let's choose another let's choose another
let's choose another
These ones are pretty cool.
But, but, because I have not reached level 200 by, uh, by,
um, at, at all yet, I would like to stay on the easier maps,
just because I will cry, if it's a harder one.
Cubism is fun.
Yeah, I like that one a lot, actually.
Kvarn, thank you!
If someone were to punt you in your Chibi model, how fun?
How far do you think you would fly asking for science?
With your legs?
I wouldn't even budge.
Don't skip leg day, everybody.
Resort?
That's like the easiest one, isn't it?
I think we could get to level 200 at resort.
Maybe.
Right?
Let's try it.
I'll even do hard mode, though.
I'll do hard mode.
Yeah, I'll do hard mode still.
I'm going to put her there.
Easy mode for easiest?
No!
I want to reach it.
I want to reach level 200.
Wait, how long have I been streaming for?
Two hours?
I need to make...
You just starred.
Yeah, I'm just starting.
I will also put in a mortar monkey so that we can get more
experience for him.
Oh, I should close these.
There we go.
Look at the little rockets here.
And of course, it wouldn't be...
Without our beloved ice monkey relaxing on vacation.
Yeah!
How much is he anyway?
Okay, 810.
I'll put him in next so that he can get lots of experience.
Because if we have this one, what's this one?
Super hot burny stuff that incinerates more, as long as we
get 12,000.
We'll see what happens.
We'll see.
We might not make it, but that's okay.
He's gonna melt?
No!
Yeah, yeah.
He's fine.
Look, it's She'll leave.
A little bit.
You guys, unless I ask for advice...
Please don't spam what I should do.
But I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Ice the monkey.
Oh, ice monkey.
The worst part is you're not wrong.
I've got that Slender Man build.
Nice.
Isn't Slender Man like in the sexy...
Tumblr sexy man?
Where am I thinking of the Wensler?
They're the same person, I think.
Oh, Mortar Monkey.
Sorry, Ice Monkey.
Your vacation...
is over.
They're doing construction, right?
right at the resort.
How terrible.
Just ruined his week.
There was something I wanted to put.
I can't remember what though.
Are you gonna recreate that Ice Monkey Entina Arrows?
What's wrong with you guys?
Oh, well you're wrong for Rabbit.
Fixing to go on a big hiking trip and won't be able to see
you for a couple weeks!
WEEX!
You would...
You...
WEEX!
Have fun!
Good luck!
Don't get lost, and also don't meet any serial killers!
Unless you are the serial killer, then good luck!
Don't get caught!
Make sure you clean up the crime scene!
really well.
Let's see.
Burny stuff.
Woo, woo, woo, woo.
Nice, nice.
Look at him go.
Look at him go!
Don't get caught is good advice for both sides of the serial
killer issue.
You know what?
True.
That's actually, you're actually so right.
I have to touch grass this week.
I don't want to leave my home.
After the stream, too, I have a bunch.
Well, not a bunch.
I've been...
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh.
I forgot that Sada can get that.
Oh, good.
We're fine.
Everything's good.
Everything is good.
Also, this is where Gatlin Monkey is so...
Awesome.
I wish I could just put him down here too, though, you know.
Um, I have a thing I want to put out.
I want to put on the channel.
Uh, basically, for those who don't know, I will be, uh, at a
concert on Friday.
If you're going to Anime Expo, the concert's not at Anime
Expo, but, um, there's still tickets available.
Uh, it's close to Anime Expo.
It's during Anime Expo.
So you can come and see me and some other YouTubers like Bao
and Miyori and Uttar.
And we'll be singing...
It's AX adjacent.
Exactly!
So if you're at the convention, you can come see us!
Since you're gonna go to Anime Expo in Japan...
Wait, I'm not going to Japan?
Can I recommend some anime for you to watch?
No, I'm just going to Anime Expo.
But I don't think I'm gonna have time to watch anime.
You can still recommend them, but I don't think I'll have
time, none.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Take them out!
Signal flare!
What does this do again?
Oh, the camel balloons, yeah.
Nice.
Is that the one on NYC?
Anime Expo is in LA.
Right?
Oh, Donkey!
Thanks for the raid!
Did you finish Sandland finally?
Hi, Dragoons!
Spank, thanks for the tiny gift in.
No more sands.
Yippee!
When I came in, you were fighting.
You were, like, eating?
And then you were fighting a boss?
Then she, like, rolled you over.
She literally really took you out.
Oh, my gosh.
Bring back thanks for the fencing.
Thank you so much for the fencing.
Hey, KS, thank you for the five.
T-Cup the idea.
Thank you for the five.
T-M-T-T-T-M, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
This map has sand.
Welcome back to Sandland, everybody.
Welcome back to Sandland.
You can never escape.
No.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you, guys, for all the gifting.
Alvin, Cape Barn.
Thank you, Sean.
Thank you, Krilbert.
Thank you, Murphy.
Thank you.
Hi, Zmi.
Thank you for the party.
You can never live.
You can never leave the sand.
Something something Star Wars quote.
I hate sand.
It's rough and it's coarse and it has cursed my family.
Can we go to the forest land?
I burned the forest.
I burned.
This is...
Oh, hey, guys.
Welcome back to Sand Land.
Sand land tomorrow, sand land the next day, more and more
and more sand, sand forever, sand always, sand I love it, it
gets in my bathing suit, it gets between my toes, it's so
great, sand!
Sand all the time, sand in your bed, sand in your mouth,
sand!
Once you're here, you're here forever.
Joy!
Thank you for the 50 gift, thank you!
Thank you so much.
I should probably start buying some stuff.
Let's start buying some farms.
I'm just gonna start...
Oh, why is it so hard to place these?
Wait, we can give him some shade!
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna strategize this.
One.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Two.
That's all I have.
Down.
Thanks for the 20 gift.
Thank you.
And we're going to put this guy right here.
It's still in his radar.
It's in his radius, right?
Yeah.
We're playing Bloons.
Which is like a super addictive game.
Oh my gosh.
Bloons is so addictive.
I could play Bloons for forever.
Yeah, Druid is OP.
He's really good.
Where can we buy tickets to the concert?
Let me get the link for you.
Well, here, I'll just pin it as a tweet.
You know what?
Or not a tweet.
As a...
Thing.
As a message.
I am performing.
in a concert on Friday.
Tickets here.
Copay.
Pace.
Replace pit.
Goodbye ice monkey.
0, 0, 0.
Hi, Chibi Minto.
Hello.
Nice, nice.
Okay.
So, this one will become the merchant and this one will
become the bank and then if we get another one we can have
it be the top one all right so this one's the bank this
one's the merchant both have increased
production see you and the girls on Friday meet up there he
gets back oh my gosh as soon as I get Right there I have so
many...
I have to sign stuff.
Union!
Thank you for that
gift.
Thank you for the gifted.
Why are there so many?
Why?
There's so many gifted memberships.
Marketplace.
Wait for the bank.
I have so few monkeys right now.
It's crazy.
But it's okay.
Everyone must become Wisp.
Everybody is MFers.
Oh no, they're getting loose!
Nice.
Okay, now I don't have to worry about it.
Oh, I have to worry!
You guys?
I think I have to worry.
Oh, I have no money.
What were you?
What are you good for?
Farms if you don't...
Okay, restart, restart.
Restart, restart.
But we can actually upgrade him now.
Yippee!
See, it wasn't a total loss.
Just a little bit.
I blame Doki.
Bloodlust, thank you for the study, gifted.
I was a member for two months and I never knew Wow, thank
you.
Unless you've been gifted for two months.
And thanks to those people.
Minto, you're embarrassing us.
What?
What though?
Wait until Ice Monkey hears about this.
Gosh, why is Ice Monkey so expensive?
In fact, I'm gonna start doing this.
Before Ice Monkey makes his little appearance.
See, I like to put these guys on here.
I like to have my my sets aesthetically pleasing as well you
know wait can I put a wait
why am I seeing wait why am I seeing other I think the
chat's weird for me I think so but thank you for all the
gifted basically I see a bunch of It's like, so-and-so was
gifted, gifted a membership by so-and-so.
But they're like, huh?
I think there's too many gifted memberships.
You guys, I think you broke my chat.
I think you broke my chat.
It's lagging.
What's a backlog?
You guys are breaking my...
Watch out.
Chill out.
Locked in.
We're gonna have a Gatlin monkey on every corner.
Hey, guys!
Thanks for the 20-hifted.
Alright, I know I can put him here.
A Gatlin monkey.
Gatlin!
He's so slow.
Alright, I'm going to leave it at this for now and I'm going
to upgrade these guys and get more farms and then I think
we'll be good for now.
I think.
Vila, I believe, Vila, the turtle.
Thank you.
Welcome to membership.
Membership.
We're Ice Monkey.
You guys, I barely have a house.
Good luck, charm.
Where was Ice Monkey when we were dying, huh?
Where was Ice Monkey before?
Oh, wait.
Actually, can I fit a village down here?
Hmm.
I don't think I can.
Let's see.
I'm just gonna save up enough until we get it.
Shrapnel.
Oh, wait.
Nope.
That's not saving.
Brandflakes, thanks for the five gifted.
I feel like Ice Monkey could use a friend.
Ice Monkey can hire a friend when he has enough money, okay?
Ice Monkey, mommy is not made of money, okay?
Thank you.
Oh my god, there he goes.
Yes!
Druid!
You are so OP!
Renting friends.
One's gotta do it.
what one's got to do, you know?
Okay.
Oh, maybe.
I could maybe fit it.
But I already...
Maybe I need to sell you then.
Because I like to make them fast and strong, you know.
Ice monkey friend finds... Thank you!
Maybe I'll sell him.
Yeah.
It's kind of risky right now, but if I sell him and move him
up a little bit like this and then he gets a friend they're
still like by their towels you know they're still by their
towels and then it'll fit see?
just like that awesome and then we could put something over
here probably yeah just like that okay okay okay
oh it's like 2000.
That's okay.
We're not there yet.
And then we'll get this.
Shout out to Ice Monkey!
Ah!
Jazy!
Ice Monkey Friends Fun.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Me saying I wouldn't buy anything else and just upgrade the
guys that I have.
And he'll be fast.
And then, oh.
We'll also start adding in some farms.
Come on, come on, come on.
We need to buy a new pair of shoes.
Do you think he's in radius?
How big is your radius?
Okay, he's in radius.
Okay.
This one will be...
Bank.
We need some sort of monkey emote.
Someday, I will get more emotes.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Cool.
Okay, we're gonna upgrade what we have right now.
We're gonna work with what we got right now.
Druid radius gets bigger at level 4.
Oh, really?
No way.
Whoa!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, we did it!
Oh, didn't die.
At level 40.
This is baby levels, everybody.
Baby levels.
I forgot about you, Gatlin Monkey.
I forgot you were even here.
Okay, hold on.
I'll give you some more stuff.
I forgot you were even there, Gatlin.
He's like, I'm doing my part.
How many have you killed?
Oh, actually quite a few.
He's doing his part.
Can you give the Ice Monkey a 0, 0, 0 attack shooter friend?
Attack shooter?
Attack shooter friend.
Not an Ice Monkey friend?
This.
Okay.
Ice Monkey and his life-size tack shooter that they told you
not to be afraid of.
That they told you not to be worried about.
This is the perfect relationship.
This is like, you know when there's people who are just
like, I'm in love with the Eiffel Tower.
Like I'm sexually attracted to the Eiffel Tower and I'm
going to marry the Eiffel Tower.
Or I'm sexually attracted to my boat.
That's what Ice Monkey is to tack shooter.
You know what they say?
Any hole is a gold!
Precision.
Nice.
And...
Actually, I'm gonna save up for the bank so I don't have to
hover over it anymore.
I'm lazy.
I'm lazy, you guys.
What else can we add in here?
I think we should put in a...
Who did we put at the front?
Oh!
Him!
We can put him here.
he will grab he will i will do bottom actually it's kind of
strange but i'm going to do bottom path for him so that we
can start getting some more money money
more money more
oh we're all good oh easy
peasy let's get another farm in here this one will be
Merchant.
Peeew!
Stonks for real.
Yes, yes.
Yes!
What else can we add in here?
Mortar monkey.
Also, we need some boats in here too.
Whoa!
It's also good to have a guide towards the front because the
boats can then reach there.
This hole was made for me, Ice Monkey.
So true, Ice Monkey.
Truer words have never been said, Monkey.
Wait.
I don't remember how I used to game this part.
I would, like, put something here and then the rest here...
I cannot remember.
I think I would put the flag...
really matter it's fine i'm gonna put this guy in here he's
gonna be our top route guy and i'm gonna put this guy in
here and he's gonna be our middle route guy very nice all
right let's focus on leveling these guys enzo manchini how
do you know about that guy
How do you know about Enzo Mancini?
If you don't know, basically...
Okay, so there was like this romance novel series about...
Yippee!
About some billionaire guys.
And he was one of them.
He was like the guy.
Enzo Mancini.
And...
Um, boy golly.
What a series.
Just...
It's about him and his brothers, and they're all like rich
dudes.
Amazon top seller books, of course.
What was it called again?
Oh, dirty, sexy boss is what it was called.
It was the dirty, sexy boss.
And he, like, it was about this girl who joins this, uh,
this agency.
And, I mean...
I mean, I'm sure you can infer from the title.
Is the Dirty Sexy Boss single?
No!
Because he's with the girl!
An OL?
Yeah, she was OL.
I'll be honest.
I don't know why I can't remember, so I think I just have
mentally taken it out.
Of my memory.
Oh!
It's a big boy.
That was so easy.
We took that big boy out.
I need you to do elaborate, please.
Well, I mean, what else can I say about what they went on
many escapades?
I can't infer from the title.
I remember at one point, they were like really trying to get
this baby company to join in and like drama though it's kind
of drama because
because um the guy like or the the baby company the guy took
over the the campaign the boss like the head of the company
was like you can't let a lady take this job and but the girl
the main girl she's like i understand the baby company no
one understands the baby
Picasso.
Yeah, there's something about Picasso.
Oh, Mortar Monkey!
Let's get Mortar Monkey in here.
I'm sorry, I must ruin your little date here.
I'm sorry, I have to ruin your date here, but it's gaming
time.
I've had six babies.
I don't think she has.
Look at it.
Mortar Monkey is doing nothing.
Come on, Mortar Monkey, do your job.
Maybe I should set him closer.
Come on, Mortar Monkey.
There we go.
Fireworks for them.
Fireworks!
What was the other thing that generated lives?
Oh, it was the Chinook, right?
Let's get the airplane in.
feel like I should okay what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna put
the airplane and the helicopter both in here no but I am
gonna put a village in here that's for sure that's for
certain I'm gonna put money money please never miss rapid
fire the tom nook oh no if i get the tom nook then i'm
really in trouble have you guys like played animal crossing
in it i haven't played it in a minute like a long long time
i hope my animals are okay years
ago not since 2020 yeah and you know what's so interesting
too is like for nintendo directs you never hear people being
like new animal crossing please Because it's just so sad
that they stopped the updates for Animal Crossing themselves
and, like, the actual game.
It's kind of sad.
It's all about Tomodachi Live.
I think as it went, what's it called, viral, people are
really wanting Tomodachi Live.
I'm a bigger fan of New Leaf.
I think most people are, right?
And then they were just like, yeah, by the way, this is the
last up.
update and you're like, huh?
What did you read by that?
New Leaf was so great.
I feel like New Horizons was where I suddenly felt no urge
to continue.
That's so sad.
Oh.
Sometimes I feel like I want to play again.
But also, I don't have so much time to if I casually have
time to game I'll be honest, I'm playing I'm usually playing
bloons If I can just casually game I'm like, yeah, bloons
time Oh yeah, bloons But it's also so easy I can like start
a map And then I can And then if I'm like, oh I have to work
on something Or I have to leave, I can just Save it for
later You know It's so nice Easy.
All right, let's throw in some wizard monkeys.
And in fact, I'm just going to put them all three of them
right in a row.
They're brothers.
This is the three brothers.
Three brothers!
You are the...
You are...
You are the guided magic.
You are the fire magic.
You are the intense magic.
But you also all know firewall.
Anyway, play Firewall.
And you also know this one.
Yes.
Hey, hey, hey.
This is not where you're supposed to put your wall.
What are you doing?
No, put it...
Oh, no.
What the hell?
We messed up.
This brother's gone rogue.
No!
Yippee!
Let's keep going.
He's mad with power.
I know.
It's okay.
Alright, let's see.
What else can we... Let's upgrade this first strike
capability.
Because it's really good to have.
More farms.
If you... You guys, I told you.
Stop backseating!
You convinced me to buy this cursed game and play it?
It's so fun though actually!
It's not cursed at all!
It's just a tower defense.
What's wrong with that?
What's wrong with tower defense?
How close are we anyway?
Oh, only 8,000 experience?
Yikes.
Yeah, it's literally like a dollar to get it anyway.
It's so good.
It's just a good game.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, you...
I'm gonna do this one too.
Do extra damage to ceramic.
We'll just keep it like that for now.
No farms, sell them.
Sell all the monkeys doing!
Yeah!
No farms!
No monkeys, no bloons!
Everybody's dead!
Plants versus zombies also a dollar.
That's a good game too.
So is bloons.
Okay, I want to get Spectre.
Come on, come on, Spectre!
Come on, Spectre!
Wait, what is this too?
Faster firing magic.
Oh, okay.
I know I spent money.
I have to...
Spectre!
Only attack shooter.
So far, things are not so bad.
I like when bloon pop.
I've become obsessed with bloons.
Look, we can all just play bloons together.
See, bloons all the time.
Bloons all the time.
Everybody's playing bloons.
Everybody can play bloons.
Everybody.
Everybody, if we bloons tomorrow and then bloons the next
day, day and then bloons the next day and then bloons the
next day and then bloons the next day and then bloons the
next day and then you're just like wait me too blue is it on
the menu i was waiting for it i'm like you are so right
bloons
didn't realize she had bloons brain rot too i think i just
like power defense games right all right now i'll add in
another And this one will be our top production one.
Oh, I forgot about the DDTs.
Arcanite soon.
I heard Arcanite is really hard, though.
Is that true?
I also used to play a lot of Battle Cats.
The devil on my shoulder is telling me I should play Blues.
The angel is telling me I should play Blues.
It can be difficult.
The hardest stage.
in the event at the moment.
Ah, you know, though, I feel like also Blue Archive can be
pretty difficult.
I don't think it's just me.
Oh, upgrade!
Oh!
This one.
Sky Shredder.
Whoa!
Nice.
This guy's crazy.
Okay, maybe we should get that.
But first I got to get this, the big player, right?
Um.
I'm seeing what else.
What all we got around here?
What all can be upgraded?
What should be upgraded?
What should we save up for?
What should we...
Oh, sorry.
Ice Monkey, I didn't mean to click on you.
I didn't mean to disturb you.
Blue Archive Metacombs are a special kind of hell.
I know.
Oh, God.
Oh, it's...
It's...
Yeah.
For BA, it's just stats though.
I think, well, recently I've been like, since I'm, like,
been so behind on...
Like, I'm level...
I think I just reached level 73 this morning.
So because I'm behind in levels, like, I haven't been
catching up with the story because I've just been, like...
I've just been, like, focus only on catching up.
Hard to play BA when I stare at the waifu's the entire time.
What?
They're so cute when their little TV's running around!
cute love those guys
okay um i'm gonna go for the flagship
almost almost hold oh wait i can go into debt
ready your kayako is hovercraft whack-a-mo time hey minda
was my 10-year anniversary of my Jeopardy!
episode airing a week ago!
Oh my god!
Cool Stalker!
Congratulations!
Happy 10- 10- 10 years?
Do you feel old?
How do you feel about that?
How do you feel about it being 10 years ago?
I don't know why I'm like, oof.
I don't know why I'm acting like it's a big deal.
You're the one who should be like, yeah, I feel old.
That's you.
Yes, I need a monkey.
I need a monkey.
I need a monkey!
I'm holding out for a monkey hero tonight.
He's gotta be small and he's gotta be fast and he's gotta be
all the bananas.
I need a monkey!
One second.
Ah.
Okay, sorry.
We're good.
I need a monkey.
I'm holding out for a monkey hero tonight.
What am I missing?
I mean, I'm missing a lot of things, but I'm also just like,
what am I missing?
Let's add another guy.
In fact, okay, hold on.
I said I was going to put a village here.
Hmm.
I'm trying to decide where I put it because thinking of
putting him here, I don't think he'll get re- I don't think
he'll get- he'll reach it though.
Because I want him to be the super storm monkey and then go
I'll click that.
Thank you very much.
I do need the preemptive strike to.
Put him on top of the ship?
Wait, can I put this on top of the ship?
No.
i could put him on top of the ship that is very true look at
him go
oh to the right of sada oh that's such a good idea actually
since he'll blow them all back that's a good idea good idea
good idea good idea oh i like i like having them like that
there we go yes oh did it easy hey weren't you supposed to
to strip those guys?
What happened?
What happened, guy?
What happened, monkey?
Uh-oh.
Oh.
I didn't notice the time.
It's fine.
We got this.
We got that easy.
Round 100.
Done.
Nice.
How can I upgrade here?
Maybe I'll just keep saving up a little bit for now.
I keep saving up for now.
How can you expect so much from a little monkey?
They, they, they are the ones that put themselves up to the
task!
What are you talking about?
It's them!
Oh, let's make him super duper fast.
We're halfway there, whoa!
Squidward on a chair!
This map is so easy.
Well, that's okay.
Seems SummerSales are so good for PopCap games.
Oh, that's the company that makes this, right?
You're looking extra cute today.
Oh, my God.
Thank you.
Ha-ha-ha.
Let's see.
What was I going to add?
Oh, let's add a helicopter monkey.
I'm gonna put okay hold on I'm gonna put this here for any
other monkeys that will be coming radius and I'm gonna put
him but
we're gonna go with the Apache and fast darts oh wait why
did I grab you
Does the kid, does this, does this, this, this, this, this,
sorry, I have a stutter.
Does the screen get crunchy when there's so many?
Squidward on a chair is the school anthem of the Squidward
Community College.
Oh my gosh, I forgot about my, my money.
Not so far.
How about now?
Oh my god.
Whoa, whoa, wait, wait, wait!
Where's my cursor?
Oh, oh, we made it.
Oh my god.
Ah, that was so scary.
I could have found my cursor.
Maybe it's too little, too late, but that scared me.
That really scared me.
That really freaked me out.
I think I remember having multiple preemptive strikes.
When I...
Okay, so it's this guy.
Oh, nice.
not the preemptive but the first strike capability i'm not
gonna upgrade just yet because i'm gonna get another guy
that is does that like so and the longer range and then yeah
what's the other one oh the the triple gun good triple good
Oh, I don't see Ice Monkey.
He's right here.
What are you talking about?
He's been here the whole time.
He?
Oh, wait.
How's my bank?
Nice.
It was almost maxed.
And then...
Ooh, that one was close.
That one was kind of close.
Yeah, he's just juggling.
He's just hanging out.
We got a little guard.
I'm not going to upgrade those.
Let's see.
Is there anything I can upgrade?
Is there something behind him?
I don't remember.
Nope.
Let's do the druid.
Let's save up for the druid.
My guy, my mortar guy, is not taking out all the little
shattering shells.
What are you doing?
Oh, so close.
Wait, am I...
No, I don't have enough.
The menu is accessibility that allows you to turn off
effects for most monkeys.
It helps in late game when the screen will freeze from
effects.
Oh, thank you.
I think we're good for now, but I'll keep that in mind for
later.
Oh.
We're so close.
Yes.
least have that guy all right we're just gonna go into the
next one baby keep on keep on keep it on keep on keep it on
keep on keep on nice nice nice nice go go 1 11.
oh my bananas
Nice.
I'll be honest, though.
I think this will be, like, I'm not...
Well, if I don't make it to 200 in this try, we will try
another day.
And I'll change the thumbnail.
I'll change this.
No.
Actually, I'm going to say, did you...
I'm going to say...
I'm going to change it.
I'm going to be like, did you...
200 tutorial.
How to make it to level 200 in Bloons tutorial.
obviously I'm gonna put another guy down here except this
guy will be the hydro the rocket storm locked and loaded
baby yeah go level 112 or bus what did we make in the what
did we make it in the last one.
I don't remember.
Oh, that's right.
The infamous 140.
Infamous 140.
Yeah, yeah.
How could I forget?
TDD's!
Why is there a single attack shooter on a chair?
To keep Ice Monkey company?
They're besties.
They're just keeping each other company.
You know?
As you do.
Why are you putting company in quotes?
No matter what type of company it is, it's still company.
Company is company.
Nice.
Oh, I kind of want another...
I want the middle path, maybe.
We can put that one anywhere, though, basically.
So I'm going to put it...
Because we don't...
Well, I mean...
You know what I mean.
Actually, we can put, like, a town right here.
And kind of support some guys down in this area.
So I'm going to put this guy here.
uh because well he doesn't necessarily need to be faster
does he but it's okay i'm gonna put some other guys i'm
gonna put some ninjas down there and oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oops i messed up the
timing whoa eight 21 welcome to membusha thank you That was
a little frightening.
That was a little scary, you guys.
Helicopter's freaking it.
That's why he needs help.
Wait!
This doesn't even fit down here?
Oh, yes it does.
Kind of.
Alright.
Upgrades.
We're going with the middle route.
Middle, middle, middle.
Then we'll do...
Which one?
Oh, pursuit.
Pursuit.
There we go.
Okay.
I like to not do anything.
Okay, so far so good.
I heard that.
Grab it.
Oh, there's nothing to grab.
There we go, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Level 20.
She looks so cool.
I need this guy up.
Okay, I need to stop spending useless money, I guess.
I need to make strategic calls.
I have too much performance anxiety.
Tag shooter pop stuff?
How?
Wait, how?
How does...
What?
How has tag shooter popped?
stuff.
Oh, the blimps are fat.
Oh my gosh.
He's just like, don't worry, Ice Monkey.
I'll take care of it for you.
Guys, I don't know about...
I don't know about this round.
I don't know how I'm not feeling it.
Not like this round in particular, but like this whole...
I don't know how to feel.
Hmm.
Done, done.
Welcome to member show.
Ta-goo.
Maybe we need, I need another mortar monkey in this area.
Set target here.
Like so.
My favorite hero?
Hmm.
I really like Sniper Monkey, but I think it's now Druid
Monkey.
He's gotten me out of so...
He's helped me so much.
He gets me money.
He generates me lives.
Just an all-around, really pleasant guy, you know?
In fact, if I put, like, a glue monkey here, and then the
mortar...
Wait, see, why isn't it taking it out?
Is it only for Moabs and this?
Well, that's so lame.
Unless I...
Is it...
Once this, will it take it off of these guys, the ZOMGs?
Yeah, but if I put a glue guy here, it might help it a
little bit, I think.
So, glue man!
Glue man!
We're gonna put you right there, buddy.
Glue, glue, glue, glue, glue.
It's getting pierced capped.
What's that mean?
So, like, there's too many other things.
things.
I don't think you can strip fortified from ZOMGs.
Okay, okay.
If that's the case.
Unless it needs just a little extra help, you know?
No, no, no, no glue gun there.
I've been trying to get the...
I've been trying to unlock this to the bottom for...
You know what?
Let's just stick them in there.
What's it gonna hurt, huh?
Oh, my wallet.
That's what it hurts.
It's okay though.
Why crikey?
Taking out those Moabs.
He's slightly British.
He grew up in both Australia and in Britain.
There we go.
Small purchase never hurts.
Yeah.
What are we at?
Oh, 120 seconds!
It's so fast.
Wow.
A power shopper wanted to save up for a druid upgrade.
No, no.
I got the druid upgrade.
Oh, this one.
This one over here.
Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
I messed that one up.
That one is my bad.
it's fine probably
see we're all we're like almost halfway there we're almost
even we're almost there to we're like you know we got this
actually I need to upgrade this one well we're not you know
well not anymore But you know what I mean.
Handle it.
Thank you.
Took forever.
Oh, that.
Yeah, we're going to get this guy up.
Before 140, maybe.
Who knows, actually.
At this rate, who knows?
This is not optimal.
Even for my standards.
but we could sell a few things like i could honestly sell
this for now
but other things i must keep around we have ice monkey true
true and we must believe we have ice monkey i don't even
have these guys like max Maybe it's because I've been
playing on hard.
I think I got to the 183 on...
Not easy on normal.
I think so.
I might just need to put a glue gunner up here too.
It really does help.
But it really helps around this part because there's just a
lot of good...
Good stuff over here.
Yeah, glue gunner!
Yeah!
You know what?
Let's max upgrade them even.
Yeah!
Glue his base.
I think, yeah.
It was something that I did not appreciate enough until...
until later on.
Druid 2 never be maxed.
Shh!
I'll get there!
Just you wait.
What if I put a...
Can I put...
Oh my gosh!
That's kind of fun.
Having some...
Having these two up on here?
No, no, no.
I have to save.
I have to save money!
I don't think he even does anything against the BIDs, but
that's okay.
That's okay.
Thank you.
Druid will never see level two.
No!
Look at this.
It's so great.
They just kind of stay there in place.
They're just chilling.
Have you considered putting the Druid attack speed boosters
by the Superstorm once you get them?
Wait, what do you...
What do you mean?
The Druid attack speed.
This one?
No.
This is the guy that goes crazy.
Is there like a sub-scale of this guy?
Is the bottom, Drew?
It is?
Who says that?
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, we can.
I was about to put him down, but I'd be like, we'll just let
Adam now.
134, everybody.
134.
Pop lust.
Oh, la la.
We're half...
We're- Yes, yes, yes!
Yes!
Yeah!
Squareboard on a chair!
Trying to get sideways.
This is great.
Maybe I should put another glue guy here.
He'll glue all of them up.
Once they pop too.
Okay, guys, hold on, don't judge me.
I'm just saying.
Wait, should he go here?
Yeah, he can reach.
He can reach.
Well, maybe...
Hold on.
Where does this one reach?
This one reached in the bottom?
Kind of?
No, I'm just...
Okay.
I won't go anymore.
He's just there for moral support.
I wasn't gonna...
look we're so close we'll get there where's my cursor oh my
god there's so much on this screen i can't even see my
cursor at times money save we're saving we're saving it was
why are sometimes these so much faster
oh i just opened a new window Oh my gosh.
What the hell did I just open?
Oh, I just opened the thing about Admiral Sea Battles.
What did I miss?
Did I make it?
Did I win?
Uh, what was I doing?
I was gonna click some...
Oh, I was gonna click this.
Hold on, I gotta close out of this window.
Okay, there we go.
Hey.
Anyway.
Gosh, why do you have to take so much money?
You, both of you.
No, no.
Unless...
No.
I'm loyal.
I'm loyal to the mission.
But I...
Oh my god.
No!
I wish I had filmed myself getting to 183 before so I can
remember what I did.
No!
budget busted your game.
I know!
Why is it so hard to get money?
Man.
Need more farms.
Yeah, but farms cost a lot of money!
Hey, hey, hey.
Stop spamming.
It's okay.
Like I said, It's a...
It's...
Uh, what's the word?
Why can't I...
The streaming anxiety.
Performance anxiety.
No, 138.
We were so far away from 200.
I tried.
I tried, you guys.
I'm not powerful enough.
I'll keep practicing.
I'll keep training.
And I'll get it.
I'll get it next time.
If you had 140 to 138, that's way more than 200.
You're right.
You guys, we did it.
Yippee!
We made it past 200.
Girl Math!
Yeah!
Yippee!
I don't want to use the free continue because I want to do
it without having to use the continue.
I want to do it without dying at all.
Blue and Six is on the summer sale.
Have some of the money I saved.
Thanks, Rowan.
Thank you.
Girl Math!
I feel like what we only played what two round two rounds
but that means or two games rather but that means our rounds
were good because we got we got far because played for a
couple hours what's this oh yeah I got an achievement for
destroying 5,000 COMGs oh ghost math yeah two games in three
hours is kind of crazy because it's not that much at all
it's not that much at all oh at three actually oh you're
right um no that was just a
don't worry about it don't worry about it
rounding error that even puts us even higher above 200 if
you think about it so that makes us like almost basically at
300 I think that's that's that's 318 yeah I might be the
best there ever was sorry guys you can never you can only
dream to get to my levels if you factor in ice monkey it's
at least 400 so true thanks for this fun stream amazing job
getting to round 300 thank you i would consider going longer
but since i have to get ready for my trip and stuff um i
have some stuff to do i will end it here today ah 200 or
past
I'm a little frustrated.
Thanks for Bloom's Brain Ride.
Just curious what anime you're looking forward to this
month.
Nokotan and what?
Grandezer Yu.
You're gonna do what to me?
Nokotan.
I'll be honest, I don't even know what's airing this month.
I'm behind a blue archive even.
I'm behind.
But I do want to watch Nookotan.
I'm interested in if it keeps, you know how like it has like
the some of the like some such such great marketing so I'm
curious how the anime will be.
I hope it's like similar to Nichi Jo.
Wait.
Oh.
Cry nuka nuka nuka nuka nuka nuka nuka nuka nuka nuka nuka
nuka nuka nuka nuka nuka nuka nuka nuka nuka nuka nuka nuka
nuka nuka nuka nuka Nuka Nuka Nuka Nuka Nuka Nuka Nuka Nuka
Nuka Nuka Nuka Nuka Nuka Nuka Nuka Nuka Nuka Nuka Nuka Nuka
Nuka Nuka Nuka So it's okay.
What balloons do you ship together?
All of my sniper monkeys.
Thanks for the stream, everybody.
I'm my birthday.
See you on yours.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
See you on yours.
Happy birthday.
Yeah, the bloons community.
The bloons community.
They're kind of crazy.
I'm just like, I'm just here to play monkey game.
And they're just like, more farms!
What are you doing?
I get it.
I'm like trying to get to 200.
Maybe we should calm down a little bit.
Why is the ice monkey on the chair?
Because that's where he belongs.
He's on vacation!
I need to match their energy.
If they start yelling at me, I need to yell back.
Why are you doing this?
Because I can!
The BTD6 community is very emotionally invested.
me of like uh the cookie run community i don't play cookie
run but i know that people get very serious about their
cookies i don't understand what is it about baby games that
makes people really
crazy what is it oh you are a cookie now no yeah cookie run
kingdom that's what it's called right
Just play around with only ice monkey.
Baby games are serious business.
Do you think they get like this with like Candyland and
stuff?
Well no, I guess Candyland is a little different.
You don't, there's no optimal, I mean there has to be an
optimal way to play Candyland.
Click the cookies.
The monkeys are hotter?
Boons!
Ice Monkey Only stream.
Okay, we'll do Ice Monkey Only next time.
Monkey business is serious business.
Next time we will 100%...
Well...
I'm not gonna guarantee that.
We will get to level 200.
We will do our first to get to level 200.
And we'll have an all Ice Monkey round.
Thanks for the fun stream.
Actually...
No, I was gonna say maybe I'll do it now.
But I gotta get my work done.
time.
I gotta get my work done.
I wanna, I was gonna do the ice monkey, but it's okay.
Next time.
Otamita!
Oh wait.
Uh, I see, I think the donations, the stream lab donors are
kind of backed up.
So, I see ice monkeys.
Thank you.
Ice monkeys.
I juggle.
Thank you.
try princess thank you jesse thank you mentioned already
have you seen anything about the the vsmp minecraft server a
ton of different indie and small corporal vtubers play on it
i'm sure you could get in if that would interest you i was
actually invited to not that but barry invited me to a a gta
rp server which i've never done before so i'm a little
nervous i don't want to if not invited to something though
i'm not i don't want to like get forced my way in so but um
i have seen that some people have been playing on a on a v m
no v s i can't say this word v s mp server so um but i don't
know i don't think i'll ever stream the gta one but maybe if
you see some people if you watch some indie vtubers and you
see that they're streaming it I might be in there someday.
I don't know.
BeatTuber Survival Multiplayer.
Is that what it stands for?
I never knew.
I've only ever...
The first time I ever heard about it was from Dream.
What is it?
The DSPM?
No.
That's Deer Stage Perfect Music.
Oh, SMP.
Sorry, I don't know anything about Dream.
Oh,
get on the DSPM Minecraft server.
And Nan, thank you.
I see your anime recommendations.
Area 88.
Wait, that's old.
That's not new.
But thank you.
oh wow this duck i just saw yours come in what you're saying
is when barry starts the server we can expect a random
cardboard box on the side walk to from time to time maybe if
i have time i kind of she she was like no pressure and i was
like nervous because i never done a server like that before
so i was like i don't i've never actually played gta before
either so i'm just kind of like i don't know
Good.
I hope you like it.
Thank you.
I don't know.
I've never played it.
If you guys are interested in me playing GTA, I'll try it.
Because it looks fun.
I've never watched anyone play it before either.
Because I was like, if I ever want to play it someday,
I'll...
Not...
I don't know.
Is that a game with spoilers?
I don't know anything about it, to be honest.
So...
Like single player?
Yeah, I guess so.
Yeah.
I don't know.
But anyway.
Reminds me of winning you at GTA 5 on your final schedules a
few years back.
Oh, those years ago?
Why did I not do it?
I can't remember at all.
She's gonna run Civilian Overtrust.
Yeah, probably.
Got a pretty good story mode.
No way, really?
Okay, cool.
Well, guys, okay.
That's all tomorrow.
Finishing Metal Gear Solid 1.
And...
Yeah, I'm gonna go work on my stuff now.
I should have some, like, shorts that go up while I'm gone.
And also, if I can get this other video done, I'll have a
special video.
I'm kind of nervous about Because I've never put up this
kind of video before So
But yeah I'm doing all the editing myself Anyway Anyway I
will see you guys tomorrow And if not, I will see you guys
the next time I catch you
Bye bye, Otomita!
Bye bye!
Thank you guys, thanks for watching!
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye!